And most of the tickets, sometimes they are the first contact. So it's really important that, you know, that service quality thing is being focused on. So I'll be working with Ashish for, I believe, for next week mainly on that quality thing. So all the feedbacks that we have, I'm collecting from our clients and all that, I'm summarizing that this week.
So, we'll be able to focus more on on what what we want to focus on actually on on the quality improvement side.
Sure, yeah, that'll be helpful because then we would be able to work with them on the ground as well to align them in terms of your expectations, okay? Okay. And yeah, I think we're hopeful that the interview goes well for the replacement. He is one of the MSP experienced engineers that we were fortunately able to.
Yep.
Mm.
get him out. He was about to, he's about to finish from one of his projects, so hopefully, you know, you like him.
When you say MSP for experiences, just MSP in common or MSP Corp experienced?
No, not MSP Corp, as in MSP as in MSP, yeah. So he has been associated with us for over two, three years now. He has worked with some major clients and, you know, and of course, he's wrapping up in one of the projects. So yeah, fortunately, we were able to take him out for this opportunity.
Okay, got it.
Got it, got it. Well, that's good.
Industry.
That's good.
Okay, that's good.
Yep.
Perfect, perfect.
Okay, anything specific, anything that you see that is worth bringing up as a part of, in a positive science that you see for the team and anything which you see that is a red flag that we need to be aware of specifically?
Yeah, positive thing. What I would say is just the cohesiveness in with our existing team here, like how they're blending in and working as a team. That's I'm noticing that constantly that that's improving. And yeah, just responding to our trainings and all that, that's going well as well.
Yeah, it was for, I guess, for last little while, the only red flag was the amount of negative reviews we piled up, especially at our negative at our London office. And that was, I believe, Ashish, we noted that as well. I believe in the.
Yep.
Yeah, like there were like 4 negative reviews just for I guess Ashish at a point, but after that we haven't seen that come up again, like in that fashion. So, so that's good. But yeah, we just want to go focus that that stays that way. So yeah, this feedback collection would help, I guess, in that direction.
Sure.
Hundred percent, and mayor.
Yeah, please, please.
Sorry, I was just completing my thought there. Do you do we have a visibility of what percentage of surveys was sent, how many were responded, and then what is the positive CSAT percentage and what is the negative or neutral? Do we have anything that specifically talks about for a duration, let's say monthly?
I'm sorry.
or month on month trend.
Yes.
I'm not sure what access you have on BrightGauge, but I use BrightGauge as well for that purpose. So there should be like a CSAT BrightGauge was that ever shared with you, Ashish Amit.
No, I never given access to it.
No, nope.
Key.
All right, so I guess that was on, Jeremy was working on some things. So I'm meeting Jeremy today. That is something I can discuss with him on where we are with that. Another portion is the Luware access that we were discussing. So that is also.
Okay.
I was about to come to that.
Yeah, we are discussing today because we want to again monitor how we are doing at like answering calls and all that. And the way we have it set currently is not helping us. So we are rolling out BlueWare at both offices, Gulf and London. And as we are doing that, I want to ensure that if there is any reporting piece, we can give you access to.
Kip.
that would be helpful as well. So I'm discussing that with Jeremy today.
Yeah, no, definitely. That keeps us on top of the things in terms of understanding that how team is moving, where the focus is needed. And at the same time, when we're meeting for these reviews, we certainly can have some data-driven conversations as well. So that'll be really helpful. Okay.
Yep.
Yeah, I would really like to get to that point where we are just, yeah, data.
It.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, and I guess a similar kind of thing would apply for Jessel's pod as well when we're building the Bride gauge reporting.
Mm.
Would that apply for Jessalyn team as well? Or is it specific to your team, Mayor?
Excellent.
Yeah, I believe tools technology-wise, we are both of us, so Jessel's team already is on Luware, so if we roll out something, it will be much faster with Jessel for reporting, and otherwise the ride gauge is again common for us.
Yes.
So both the solutions, whatever we find out, I guess would be applicable to, yeah, both of us.
Yeah, cool.
Thank you. Ashish, anything else from you?
Nope, I'm all set. Mayor, just one request regarding the seaside surveys for the engineers that have been triggered for the month of April. So please appreciate if you take out some time and fill it for the guys.
Yes.
For sure, yeah, I'll get it then.
Yeah, I think we can re-trigger it right now so that it stays on the top of your inbox. I mean, so this is specifically for April and for May, of course, once it is completed, we'll trigger at that time. So yeah, just for reference, how the team performed in the month of April.
I'll do that.
Sure.
N.
Sorry, sir, were you saying something?
Thank you, Amit. Thank you for bringing this. On the same note, we are pending service for the month of Feb and March too. So Ash, while you will be sending it out, could you please send it for Feb and March?
Sure, I'll first take it for April and then I'll do it for today.
Oh, I thought that were completed, but yeah, let me, yeah, if you can send that again, any pending ones, I'll complete that.
Sure, thank you.
Alright, Mike, anything from you?
No, nothing from me.
Okay, all right. So I guess one of the things would remain as a follow-up action, Mike, is, you know, you looking into the progress from the time when the feedback was shared versus now, because we are confident that the team is now following the escalation templates that you talked about on the back of the feedback that was received. So.
I.
Kip.
Yeah, if you can please do some sanity checks and let us know. At least we will understand that, you know, the feedback is lended well.
Absolutely.
All right, cool. Karine, anything from you?
Nope, nothing I can share there. I will call you later.
Sure, okay, cool.
Sure, great, absolutely. Okay, so I guess we're good. Mayur, thank you for your time. Thank you for your time, Mike, to you as well. We are re-triggering the CSAT service so that you can fill it for the specific month so that we know how the team is performing. And of course, we circle back and hopefully Mayuri will like the candidate that he will meet.
Yep.
And you know, we should be able to get him started as soon as possible. Rest, if anything comes up, we, as you know, you're already available on chat, right? We'll try to stay on top of the things.
Yup.
Sounds good.
Alright, thank you. Thanks, everyone. Thank you, Karine. Cheers. Thank you, Team.
All right, thank you so much.
Thanks, everyone.